did you do print UPS of all yours not my
first one cuz I did it in Vegas you did
it in Vegas you've been married in Vegas
oh my gosh you can just walk through the
whole thing then Little White Chapel
that's exactly why we're doing it oh my
God I wonder if they remember you take a
picture on the wall what did you just go
and do it one night or do you plan it no
no no not planned just went and did it
you have pictures no I don't have a
thing so you just got married on them
more and then I don't know I don't
remember it's men's to be where should
we go after we should do something we
have to go to the Usher concert are you
guys you never win CU you couldn't land
no yes perfect after the concert we get
tattoos oh my God perfect and then wait
will you get a tattoo though no what
about on your little toe no I don't do
feet tattoo no really in the didn't you
do things yeah you guys something you
don't know about
me what did I say it's a inity song
when did you do that